all right Mattia yes Mattia where'd you
grow up
where you from very fine watts telephony
and tell me about your family you grew
up with both of your parents help would
you who's who raised you basically
straight but my mother's 15 SHANY
my father I only met her three times in
my life
you only met your dad three times yes
where was he in a physical murder murder
very good people and how was your
childhood typical
very difficult where were some of the
hard parts dealing with me and one man
top all drugs it was I abuse from anyone
when you were a kid I just abuse case
when we meet means true big commitment
who's that man did she walk walk past
even when schools go to college to the
car we go to the car you think they want
to ask you questions had no pants on
your parents business how was true I
would have the same this was on your way
to school we're gonna know every day I
was a little fat girl one at school
every day
some days I was scared of some days I
wasn't I learned not to be scared
anymore cuz I know what's gonna happen
every day
and then what age were you when you left
home twelve and a half yeah you left
home with 12 over there where'd you go
yes the street I kind of bounced me face
to face
how's it work I got involved older man a
lot older me well how come daddy's what
what what are these older men do for you
where'd you gave me shelter so almost
like a cable what in the pit yeah hey
gave me drugs and alcohol
what was your drug back then my job back
then was heaven oh really
girl here at 12 years old yeah how's our
doubt that's really easy
Oh nah man yourself I'm not myself ears
I still know myself today and then so
your teenage years you finish high
school or no yeah man she finish high
school
that's our first high school I was right
back it is yeah son okay did you raise
your son off me
who helped you
a little bit of everybody do you still
talk to yourself oh we were not too
often
he's safe that's good expose a better
life women and I ask myself yeah good
for him and the word your life go in
your 20s spiral gamma u s+ puffin tails
tails are now calls my choice is it here
that's your go-to now the ales the
Michael team
tell him I'll fly like in it hmm any
more Quan get older I pop 30 to 50 pills
a day really alcohol and they saw those
here on Skid Row
hey Eleanor skier oh I kind of my life
Boise I was a con artist 2010 all your
stuff I needed what I need to do any
time to survive then I get the shakes
will read
then you say I call the shape I shape
he feels kind of alone a little bit it
might have to speak for me but not long
he wake up to say nightmare over me
every day every day in my life
Galliano skid-row you see everything
just say movie TV wait
you see murder you see at home yeah what
would have you done for money over the
years I've soldiers
I saw myself so myself or my dad daddy's
someone like a babies wolves like Dobby
course there's the best deal man
they're only made more gentle more
gentle a lot of time just conversation
and a lot of times thanks but I got what
I wanted to expire at it and my head was
more important anything John a time yeah
he'll do it all I made sure that the
chili was safe always how is he today
he's gone he's good he's young man good
he's young me and what do you what are
you still drinking in probably every day
then pills - and where do you find -
pretty you buy pills anybody peel some
anybody they have tents outside so you
just go to attended you know you just
you figure out yeah it's all available
here huh
anything you want I'm so drunk off TV
yes 2012 was drugs told pharmacy you can
get a parent anything you walk down
laughs you know it's obscene gesture you
know it all yeah yeah I gotta go without
how many years how many years you've
been done Skid Row
for only four yeah - I was raped on Skid
Row
I thought I could trust okay
I couldn't I jumped out of his truck but
I couldn't what a butcher knife about
this one and I went for my life where
they just went go on what's the most
dangerous thing you've run across what
somebody to kill step behind road let me
get away no reason they just snatch them
off the streets now try for they're not
same trafficking yo can you not careful
you can either the one with Chelsea gone
so he hasn't know how to be street
somewhere as well his father his drug
addiction will help all of you I learned
to grow coming up I was a big Oh nobody
in the war wasn't somebody really knows
who I am me anymore I will be not
anymore
one little thing I pull everybody called
me a good girl
I was a good girl going back very well I
did what I had to do to spice and I
still do what I asked and survive now
hold you know I do you you saw is your
mom still around
no she's my god for 29 years
oh wow I'm sorry how about you dead he's
in prison he's still in prison
yeah he's in back to me he murdered a
lot of people yeah coming up only thing
I don't know from him now is I was
traced ever ever need anything daddy
take care of it
I walked away from did you know anything
about him
Oh too much about him I come from a long
line of the criminals and criminals in
my background and I my uncle's was
criminals my auntie she only pursued
over walls to live
she's a queen queen of the plaintiff
don't claim to know you'd mentioned
outside of your dad was a pedophile yeah
and foul I need a serial killer each a
lot people the last time I seen he was
shackled like coach I can take for moose
he had a cop whose neck a cop to his
waist a cup to both forms one here one
there all together six cops
six dozen his six - I prefer guns that's
a good murder his brother in prison and
him through the jail cell
Dhani coup de agua my father's brother
from a jail cell oh I see they had no
police all the guys block the streets
for Cadillacs they refused to have a
cops near because the Cosmo dudes well
that's the last time I seen I was young
and then you also mentioned your dad was
a who's weird that's all the weird no
you say you died a serial killer he was
he killed his best friends best friends
first of all his bones were supposed to
you him his best friends as close to
things he knocked his best friend what
do i do first
happy finals best friend was sleeping
with his mom its best fairy money was
used to coming to the front door all the
time so she's sitting in the belly
so son's best friend can just do it he
blew his face off he went to jail for
five years and got up he came over again
that's the five years I wanna say she
was pregnant say she was lying he beat
her to death or bumper Jack no Tara back
in jail for five more years
yeah I back up says she was raped on the
street he walked up there to do dance
thing then to Brazil back me back in
jail again he'd just get murdered me
it's the thing they said to me they
called Wow
is wha me looking back in your life and
your parents that you were dealt and the
environment that you grew up in do do
you ever have regrets that this is the
world that you grew up in yes every day
in my life
some days I want to commit suicide some
things I don't want to live sometimes I
wish I wasn't even anymore
I tried no deal appeals before alcohol I
got my stomach pumped for anytime I
guess I guess I guess I didn't do right
yeah I mean did you ever have hope that
a better life might happen for you or a
dream ollie
I dream of a lot of things but I don't
have it I'm still out of here yeah it's
a rough way to grow up right yes it is
there's no hope there's no opportunity
there's no today I want to give up
everyday I want to give up I don't know
what keeps me going
I wake up in the morning I got my drink
I gotta have an alcohol the alcohol
numbs you from the painted noses on a
painting every day in my life I thought
it'd make me bald makers hello my boy
love me what's a boilermaker I know I've
heard it although it isn't it has beer
and how are they pitted mixed together
he makes me gamma did you do that how
early in the morning is no design get
him gear first thing in the morning here
has my coffee
that's not causing you more some days
late some day I was only a lot of days
dummy if you come to me eaten or gave
him alcohol I'm gonna take my help all
over food I don't want no food you do my
dream someday they'll wake up I don't
remember what even happened to me
anymore a lot of time I woke up my time
I walked over no clothes I don't know
what what happened to milk I didn't know
I didn't what his day I don't know what
happened to what do you do for money
today same thing same thing you've
always done yeah yeah yeah you don't
need to go details well there thank you
thank you so much for tell me you're
sorry you good luck with everything
your attitude is great despite all the
hell you been through thank you very
much yeah as well
you